alors je pensais ne pas vous poser de
question sur votre travail sur votre
main et finalement vous m'avez dit NON
NON au contraire posez-moi pour que je
puisse en parler une fois pour tout
la parole
de cadre mon cahier parce que Abel
Ferrara absolument que je ferme mon
cahier et que je fasse cette émission
sans fiche voilà Google
comment vous appelez-vous parce que sans
mes fiches je suis perdu
bon alors vous jouez dans le film de
d'andrées ciné on a un qui a fait
l'ouverture du festival vous avez eu des
échos de l'accueil
sont nombreux je crois que les gens qui
ont pas tellement apprécié la cérémonie
d'ouverture le son d'avantage encore et
qui doit être un petit peu mêlé comme ça
c'est la première fois vous venez à
Cannes et alors évidemment quoi la
question elle est un peu bête mais quel
effet ça fait c'est à dire puisqu'on
sait que vous avez trempé quand même pas
mal dans les milieux de cinéma est-ce
que ça correspond à l'image que vous
vous en faisiez est-ce que c'est
différent est-ce que ça correspond plus
ou moins l'image que je m'en faisais
ouais à la fois un truc excitant et en
même temps
angoissant un peu non c'est ça
correspond plus ou moins parce que je
voyais ça à la télé et tout c'est quelle
image du cinéma à votre avis ça renvoie
quoi parce qu'on a quand même
l'impression qu'on est tous
représentation qu'on peut pas traverser
la rue et à l'épicer sans se croire dans
un film enfin c'est vrai que c'est un
peu curieux oui il y a un
[Musique]
je sais pas comment on le voit les gens
à la télé enfin moi longtemps à la télé
j'avais l'impression que c'était un truc
effectivement comme ça un peu où on a
l'impression que tout à coup autour de
Cannes il y a plus rien qui se passe que
tout est là donc ça fausse un peu le
ouais ça fausse un peu les choses mais
bon c'est quand c'est la première fois
c'est quand même excitant parce qu'on
est là dans la rue et puis alors on
traverse et puis on voit qu'il y a
machin truc qui achète son journal
bidule qui sort d'un café c'est c'est un
peu comme une maquette avec tous les
petits bons hommes c'est marrant c'est
marrant et quand vous aviez vous le
regard sur le Festival de Cannes par
rapport à votre père ou à votre mère ça
ressemblait à ça ou c'était très
différent la réfraction que vous en
aviez c'était quoi en fait
j'avais pas vraiment une image de canne
par rapport à c'était des images
d'archives au moment des Parapluies de
Cherbourg par rapport à ma mère ou des
choses comme ça mais c'était déjà un
film pour moi puisque à cette époque là
je la connaissais pas donc c'est déjà de
la fiction ça n'a pas vraiment de cesser
tellement différent quand on quand on y
est c'est en fait c'était plus je me
faisais plus une image par rapport à ce
que je vois à la télévision qui est
concret et pas par rapport à mes parents
j'ai je crois que j'ai jamais vu l'image
de mon père à Cannes
en noir et blanc déjà le fait que ce
soit déjà des archives et que ce soit en
noir et blanc des déjà ça peut pas il y
a pas d'éléments de comparaison en fait
ce que vous avez la journée type d'une
bonne festivalière est-ce que vous allez
voir des films ou sur la plage enfin en
fait je j'ai été un peu dépassée par les
événements je comprenais rien aux
accréditations au fait qu'il faut avoir
des places aussi
j'ai pas de pastille j'ai non hiérarchie
des pastille je sais pas laquelle c'est
ce qui permet d'entrer dans tel ou tel
salle moi j'ai pas du tout ça j'ai eu
des petits ce qui s'est passé quotidien
disons c'est périmé à la fin de la
journée mais je n'ai pas les places
enfin je mange une petite nouvelle je me
suis vraiment mal démerdée
le film Agnès Varda en réalité et alors
votre réaction ça m'a beaucoup plu
vraiment j'ai trouvé ça formidable mais
j'ai pas vu tous les autres films qui
sont en compétition le pourquoi vous
l'avez trouvé formidable le film
Daniel's bardah qui était notre invité
avant-hier parce que je trouve qu'elle a
réussi à faire d'une chose qui a priori
est triste puisque Jacques Demy et
Françoise Dorléac ne sont plus là elle
elle a réussi à faire complètement
oublier ça c'est vraiment un moment de
bonne un instantané de bonheur on a
l'impression qu'en sortant de la salle
on va tout à coup les voir il y a c'est
jamais larmoyant c'est c'est filmé avec
beaucoup d'amour moi c'est j'ai été et
puis j'étais très ému de voir des des
images d'archives comme ça on les voit
répéter à Londres toute petite enfin moi
j'avais jamais vu j'avais jamais vu ça
quoi
là vous voyez votre mère dans cette
situation là quel type de regard on a
c'est-à-dire est-ce que est-ce que c'est
un regard un petit peu objectif
c'est-à-dire on voit la comédienne
Catherine Deneuve est-ce que c'est
quelque chose d'évidemment plus trouble
que ça d'autant plus que elle était très
très jeune dans dans ce film là et
surtout dans les images on les voit
répéter et on est parlé donc il y a un
décalage énorme entre entre le fait que
bon elle était vraiment au tout début et
maintenant elle parle différemment il y
a une espèce de maturité qui s'est faite
et donc moi j'ai quand je vois ça je
suis d'autant plus émue alors je pensais
ne pas vous poser de questions sur votre
papa et sur votre bain et finalement
vous m'avez dit NON NON au contraire
posément pour que je puisse en parler
une fois pour justement
une déclaration donc à la France une
déclaration la France toujours les
habituels questions sur mes parents et
on ne les retranscrit pas à par écrit ce
qui fait que je n'arrive pas à m'en
débarrasser donc voilà ça ne me pose pas
de problème en fait pour toutes j'ai
essayé quoi
[Musique]